avec vos julien shahida ce matin bonjour
julien bonjour avant d'évoquer
l'actualité en france on commence par ce
récit absolument glaçant julien de
l'exfiltration des deux derniers
journalistes étrangers qui étaient
encore présents à mario paul ville
assiégée dans l'est de l'ukraine
effectivement le britannique métro ont
fait même sa une s'échapper de marioupol
c'est le récit très documenté des vingt
jours qu'on passait ses deux
journalistes de l'agencé américaine et
hippie près de trois semaines durant
lesquelles ils ont couvert la vie de
cette ville sous les bombardements
incessants de l'armée russe rappelez
vous ces images pauline du bombardement
de la manette la maternité il ya
quelques jours l'image qui avait choqué
l'opinion et bien c'est à ces deux
journalistes qu on doit ces images dans
un très long russie + récit publié sur
le site d'el pais on découvre les
conditions dans lesquelles ils ont
travaillé et les raisons aussi qui les
ont poussé à rester en dépit des risques
des dangers qu'il y avait pour leur vie
il y avait ce besoin vital distille de
témoigner car sans information la ville
sombre et à vitesse grand v dans le
chaos on y découvre aussi la façon dont
ils ont dû quitter précipitamment la
ville c'était il ya quelques jours
seulement les russes en outre à qui il
avait une liste de noms dont les nôtres
et il se rapprocher du style ce sont
finalement des soldats d'ukrainiens qui
sont venus les chercher dans un hôpital
où ils étaient en train de travailler et
qu'ils ont intimé de quitter prestement
les lieux et surtout la ville au risque
d'être fait prisonnier et ensuite
manipuler par les russes un récit
poignant et édition édition qu'il faut
lire absolument pour comprendre les
difficultés qu'il ya à couvrir cette
guerre sur le terrain en ukraine les
dangers qu'il ya pour nous journalistes
mais aussi comprendre la nécessité de
couvrir nous faire en sorte que c'est le
quotidien de ses habitants ne soient pas
oubliées il n'y a aujourd'hui plus tôt
la liste étrangers à marioupol dans ce
conflit julien deux personnalités
s'affiche en une de la presse française
ce matin et non des moindres le couple
présidentiel ukrainien le couple
présidentiel pardon oui en figures de la
résistance et chrétienne exactement je
propose ces deux portraits croisés et du
couple pendant du couple zelensky avec
d'un côté est la première dame qui donne
sa première interview à un média
européen depuis du début du conflit dans
le parisien et de l'autre libération qui
revient
une nouvelle fois sur la figure
charismatique de volodymyr zelensky ou
alors comment l'ancien comédien élu
président il y a deux ans et contre
toute attente devenu ce que libération
appelle l'homme de la situation pour le
quotidien de gauche cette guerre dont on
ne connaît pas encore l'issue restera
dans les mémoires pourquoi pour sa
brutalité pour sa violence mais pas
seulement parce que leur a permis écrit
l'édito de révéler les toffes d'un chef
celui du président ukrainien en phase
avec en face la monstrueuse était froide
et d'un président russe prêt à tout
pulvériser ont parlé hier avec vous
julien des inquiétudes quant impossible
envois d'armes non conventionnelles par
la russie emploi pardon aujourd'hui la
question ne se pose de savoir si
l'occident à une ou plusieurs lignes
rouges alors officiellement pauline il
n'y en a pas mais d'après le figaro
l'occident veut surtout éviter un
nouveau fiasco comme en 2013 vous
explique en 2013 il y avait sept emplois
d'armes chimiques par le régime de damas
qui était la ligne rouge de l'otan
synonyme c'est-à-dire de riposte
militaire sauf que damas ensuite avait
utilisé ses armes sur sa population sans
que l'occident interviennent
militairement au final face aux horreurs
de la guerre en ukraine et face à la
peur d'une escalade du conflit le figaro
explique que l'otan continue de soutenir
mid et halit militairement kiev tout en
renforçant ses effectifs dans les pays
baltes alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de riposte militaire prévu tant que les
frontières de l'otan ne seront pas
touchés mais entre l'action et une
action il faudra un moment de choisir
conclut l'article et surtout à chum
assumer le choix qui sera fait et sur la
menace de la contagion reviendra à 7h40
dans le décryptage avec bilal tarab et
elles ont choisi de rester et l'assument
complètement ces grandes enseignes
françaises qui n'entendent pas quitter
la russie pour des raisons économiques
effectivement selon ministère de
l'économie il reste encore environ 700
entreprises françaises implantées en
russie dont beaucoup sont issus du
groupe du cac 40
et pas question de se cacher dans le
parisien le fabricant renault par
exemple affiche clairement ses arguments
renault emploie trois sites de
production et 40000 personnes sur place
et la russie constituent aussi le
deuxième marché pour le constructeur
mobile automobile après la france pour
les gérants de l'agrémenter de
l'agroalimentaire il n'y a pas vraiment
d'argument économique mais plutôt
appelons ça un argument humanistes sont
eux car en pleine guerre distille il
faut bien nourrir la population russe le
géant total très décrié lui refuse tout
simplement de partir il n'y aura tout
juste plus d'investissements futurs à
court terme en russie officiellement
rappelle le parisien rien n'oblige les
entreprises françaises a quitté la
russie en dépit des sanctions
internationales
voilà pour l'actualité en ukraine
interviendra dans dans un instant en
france julien il était l'un des détenus
les plus célèbres du pays le militant
indépendantiste corse yvan colonna est
donc décédé cette nuit des suites de son
agression en prison avec son visage qui
s'affiche en une de corse matin et ses
mots très simples yvan colonna est mort
mort d'une figure du nationalisme corse
qui était-il pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas je vous invite à lire le
papier très complet d'ariane chemin dans
le monde qui retrace le parcours de cet
ancien berger donc mort à 61 ans devenu
militant politique puis l'un des fers de
lance du mouvement indépendantiste corse
à partir des années 70 pour dire les
choses triera très rapidement et lille a
connu une vague de contestation pour
s'affranchir peu à peu de l'état
français il ya eu d'un côté des actions
pacifiques et de l'autre les actions
extrêmement violentes du flnc le front
national de libération de la corse en
parallèle de cet article est de cette
histoire on suit tout le parcours dit
yvan colonna jusqu'à cette soirée
fatidique du 6 février 1998 date de
l'assassinât du préfet erignac pour
lequel yvan colonna aura été condamné à
perpétuité
et depuis son incarcération sa vie
s'écoulait très lentement conclut
l'article il est mort à 61 ans sans
amarres sans avoir jamais revu son île
merci beaucoup julien c'était la revue
de presse à tout à l'heure dans paris
direct